what's going on guys this is rob and
we're a couple days late to this party
but i think it's okay uh the boys season
three trailer drop now
this season's gonna be insane one
because it looks like it's gonna have
herogasm and two because
if they do have herogasm and they do the
aftermath of herogasm
it's gonna end on one hell of a
cliffhanger uh so parents this video is
not for the kitties
so shuffle them out of the room and let
us continue so here's the thing this may
have spoilers for season three honestly
i don't really know i don't know how far
they're gonna take it as far as i'm
aware amazon seems to just kind of be
playing it by ear right they renewed it
for season three but there hasn't really
been any discussion about season four uh
so with the way the series is right now
and just what we've seen in the trailer
in terms of what's gonna happen
honestly they could do four seasons and
then call it a day they could literally
wrap up the show in four seasons having
said that it's it's oh my god i'm
excited okay so again potential spoilers
here
this is gonna be nuts so there's a few
things to know one
things are about to get wild and there
is something that i'm curious to see if
they're gonna introduce in the show
which is the team team now these guys
were nuts you know i don't know why i
called them the teen team that's the
name of the team from invincible
the teenage kicks uh these guys are nuts
it's it's crazy the kind of stuff they
do i mean technically we kind of seen
them a little bit like if i recall
correctly from season two mesmer was
talking about how his time on the
teenage kicks that there was like some
crazy stuff that went on i know we saw
popclaw uh they had that whole thing
with her and like a train was a member
of the the teenage kicks at one point
but like in the comics you get full-on
view of the teenage kicks and the thing
is it's like one of huey's first
assignments and literally when he's
observing them the introduction we get
to the teenage kids this is why i say
the kitties don't need to be here for
this stuff the the introduction we get
to the teenage kicks is that they're
basically
they're basically all like sleeping with
different women in this like i think it
was a hotel or like their apartment or
whatever but like each member has a girl
in their room and then what will happen
is they'll you'll switch and they'll all
jump they'll all switch rooms and
they'll do that over and over and over
again but because of the fact that you
deal with different things like super
strength or you have like insane levels
of stamina it gets to the point where it
just becomes this brutal bloody mess
like it's absolutely insane and huey's
just like what in the hell right it's
just it's it's nuts to watch and they
have like a really really dark history i
mean i don't want to see like all the
nasty terrible brutal stuff but the
teenage kicks was this really really
cool concept because what it basically
showed is that vaude didn't really have
any rules when it came to the
superheroes so long as they didn't
tarnish their public image they could
essentially do whatever they wanted to
do and then beyond that you go into like
herogasm now this is probably one of the
most insane parts of the entire boys
series so the way this worked at least
in the comics anyway it's like
homelander in the seven show up and
they're like okay guys there's an alien
invasion coming so like we're going to
be gone for a few days while we deal
with these guys but don't worry
everything's safe it's all going to be
cool you guys are going to be protected
and uh and then in turn like they
basically fly off to this private island
that's owned by vaught america and then
vaught basically flies in hookers from
everywhere men and women right they fly
they fly people in who are just willing
to have sex for money and it's just this
enormous orgasm that involves like other
superheroes and like just normal people
and all that kind of stuff of course
they're paid huge amounts of money i
think it's something like 250 grand a
person or something like that for the
people who come out there i don't know
what the exact number is they do say it
in the comics but i think it's just one
of those passing statements but it quite
literally is just a giant orgy on a
private island involving a combination
of super powered beings and normal
people it's crazy right and it's like
this annual thing that they always do i
think it's annual but like they do it
basically to keep the superheroes in
check and the reason why is because if
something like that didn't happen the
superheroes would pop a rivet right just
like all the stress and all that kind of
stuff now queen maeve has her stuff
sorted out in the show she's a lot she's
she's not really anything like she is in
the comics i mean she's obviously got
problems in the show in the comics she's
an alcoholic and she's taking dudes like
two at a time right it's crazy like
she's just like bodybuilders right
because like they're the only ones that
have the stamina they can basically like
they can keep up with her uh it's pretty
wild right it's pretty raunchy obviously
they toned it down for the show for
obvious reasons but the fact remains
that he orgasms nuts now there was a
news article that came out recently
where like they interviewed members of
the cast and they were like yeah we
recorded herogasm and like it
traumatized us all
it was it was pretty wild like it's it's
a crazy thing so i feel like we're we're
not going to see uh herogasm in the same
capacity that we saw it in the comics
but we are going to see a version of it
and the version of it that we saw seems
pretty intense now here's the biggest
reason why herogasm matters not because
of of the events of herogasm which is to
say like all these different superheroes
banging but because of what came out of
it because it's it's like one of the
things you guys have noticed over the
course of the tv show is that
homelanders just become more and more
unstable now i will not dump the huge
revelation for homelander because that
would be a ridiculously colossal spoiler
so i won't reveal that here but what i
will say is not everything is what it
seems when it comes to homelander and
i'll leave it at that but uh but it's
nuts right like he's obviously going off
the rails losing his mind becoming less
and less stable as time goes on the
circumstances surrounding that in the
show are a little bit different than
they are in the comics there are
characters whose roles have shifted up
different things like that but the
overall theme is that homelanders
basically going nuts and so what happens
in herogasm in the comics anyway is at
the end of it all he's just like why are
we answering to vaude american like we
could literally overpower these guys at
any point in time so let's just do that
let's just take out vod american and
let's just conquer the world and so
literally he he like organizes the
superhero community and they basically
launch an attack to conquer conquer the
world and there comes a point where he
takes over the white house now i don't
know if that's gonna happen they may
totally shift things up again that's why
you got a potential spoiler alert at the
beginning of this video
but regardless there's crazy things that
go on now in the trailer
the sun oh my god the son of billy
butcher right like if you look at that
he's got superpowers there's a reason
for that but that's why i say
not everything with homelander is what
it seems
you know that's that's the cool thing
about this like the footage that we saw
on the trailer that goes pretty deep
into into the into the boys like quite
literally if you take the tv show and
you just kind of track it with the
comics the way with all the footage and
everything that we saw in the show they
could end season three and we'd be like
one story yard from the conclusion of
the boys and that would be it like you
could quite literally wrap up the final
season in like three episodes you know
obviously i don't think they're gonna do
that they're gonna stretch it out for as
long as they can but i do think they're
gonna cap it at four seasons right so
how long they how many episodes they do
with with season four i don't entirely
know but i think they're gonna cap it in
four seasons and the reason why is
because i don't really see them having
enough source material to move beyond
that point uh now there are other cool
things that go on because one of the
things that i don't think we necessarily
know is the origin of vaude american i
guess technically it's called vaught
international but there was an article
that was published by collider in
what is it december of last year where
they were talking about how season three
would explore more of vaughn's past
because here's the thing how vaught came
to be
is really cool to be honest with you
guys i mean they're a shady company it's
they've got like they do some terrible
things but how they came into existence
is actually really really fascinating
because it's believable
it's 100 believable that a company like
that could come into existence that way
but yeah they've got a really really
fascinating backstory but there's a lot
of questions that we don't necessarily
have answered and so looking at the
footage that we saw in season three and
then or at least the the trailer for
season three and then looking at like
the different interviews that have been
done with like the writers or the
director or the cast members or whatever
it is season three looks like it's gonna
be insane now there is a potential
danger to this right because of
everything that they're covering in
season three it could be a little too
much right it could be one of those
things where it's just kind of like okay
there's a lot happening here having said
that i mean the ability to cover the
history of vaught i mean you could do
that in like a 10 minute segment right
like literally in the comics this is a
one shot like i don't even know if it's
a one shot it's like half of a comic
book maybe a whole comic book or
something like that but it's like a
single book right in this great big huge
expansive thing which would have
would equate to like a 10 minute segment
in a tv show given how much extra fluff
they put in there and different things
along those lines but yeah i mean i'm
i'm really excited for because here's
the other crazy thing
we haven't seen mother's mother's milk's
mom have we like i'm pretty sure we
haven't uh because in the comics oh my
god mother's milk's mom it's crazy like
like she it's
man it's it's wild but that's why i say
like the you know everything that you've
seen with vaughn has largely been on
like the front face what's going on in
the current moment with like giancarlo
esposito and like the leader of the
person who ran it before him and like
all those crazy things what was
elizabeth shu's character i can't
remember her name before a homelander
incinerated her face which was pretty
gruesome
but kind of one of the coolest scenes in
the show
i'm not even gonna lie not even gonna
lie to you guys it was brutal
but it was kind of cool at the same time
but like we've only ever really seen
vaught on the front face the stuff
they've done to get to where they are
now oh my god those of you guys who read
the comics do you remember the pageant
like the kid pageant do you remember
that they're okay so i don't know what
they're gonna do in the show there's
this one point where they they run like
a pageant because what they do is they
basically like uh you know they
okay so a little bit of a spoiler i
don't know if they're gonna do this for
the show but the way the vaught works is
oftentimes what they'll do is they'll go
to parents who are like expecting
children but are on financial hard times
and they'll say like we'll inject you
with compound v for like x amount of
money and sometimes they'll take their
kids sometimes they won't it depends on
the kids themselves and like what powers
they develop and so on and so forth a
lot of parents will take the money right
like they'll just kind of be like well i
mean i could my child could potentially
be a superhero and the reason why is
because they don't know the darker side
because what happens is like when
something goes awry vaught will
immediately sweep it under the rug and
they'll pay a ton of hush money to those
families and make them sign an nda write
a non-disclosure agreement so they'll
never talk because if they do vaughn
will take that money back then they'll
sue them or probably have them killed or
something along those lines so there's a
point in the comics where there's this
pageant that's being put on and it
involves like these young kids and they
all really kind of have powers in some
way there's this girl she's got heat
vision and this girl can't be any more
than like five or six years old and
basically i think either her powers
activate in the pageant or the pageants
there to showcase her powers and her
heat vision melts her eyeballs in her
head and so like literally her eyes are
just like melting out of her head and
she's screaming and crying and vaught
comes in and just whisks her away i'm
paraphrasing the scene here but
nonetheless it's i mean it's stuff like
that right like the kind of stuff
thoughts into like it's it's brutal man
and that's why i say some of it it might
be a little too extreme even for an
amazon prime series but they might
showcase it just to illustrate how
terrible of a company vaught really is
because the i mean you look at him and
you're like okay this company seems
pretty shady no you have no clue just
how awful
vaught is and just how little they care
about like just the average person like
it's it's some of the stuff they do is
sadistic man it's absolutely nuts
especially the whole thing with black
noir
man oh my god that's absolutely insane
but with that being said guys uh let me
know if you're excited about the boys
season three because like i said season
three looks like it's gonna be insane
i'm really excited about it right i'm
really really hyped about it let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section and i will catch you all later
peace